elles sont parfois jugées suspicieuse
les attributions de places en crèche
l'association des maires de france a
choisi de créer une charte pour
accompagner les élus et faciliter les
échanges signé par lui en cour le 29
août dernier
la commune propose près de 400 berceau
pour l'instant très honnêtement ça nous
a permis de réfléchir quand même sur la
façon d'améliorer nos pratiques alors
des choses qui peuvent paraître très
anecdotique mais par exemple où on a mis
en place depuis notre décision de signer
cette charte de dresser par exemple un
procès verbal à la suite de chaque
commission une signature à la demande
des communes le texte a été pensé autour
de dix orientations les communes
s'engagent à faciliter les démarches
d'inscription et à ajuster lés critères
au fil du temps
à partir du moment où une famille vient
voir le maire ou l'adjointe au maire
oulhadj en mai jusqu'au moment où on va
lui dire madame vous avez une place au
madame vous n'avez pas de place au sol
et il ya trois étapes 1 dans
l'attribution il y a le rendez vous avec
les familles très important le premier
lit ensuite la commission d'attribution
qui se réunit qui va statuer et il y a
près le retour que l'on fait aux
familles elle la petite enfance n'est
pas une compétence obligatoire pour les
villes si commune yvelinoise ont déjà
signé cette charte
guyancourt rejoint notamment versailles